right moving on to item one apologies
for absence I think everyone is here so
uh welcome everyone so no need for any
apologies uh non-members attending we're
getting used to this councilor Wilson
but we welcome our councilor Stuart
Wilson who I feel is part of the family
of the executive now because he always
reports back on issues from overview and
scrutiny and uh and thank you very much
indeed for your time and attendance and
we quite understand that you have
appointments later on so understand if
you want to leave the meeting once your
item has been concluded
um minutes of the meeting held on uh it
seems a long while ago now 13th of July
are those minutes agreed members
fairly lengthy
racing so I can sign and they're
approved lovely thank you
any Declarations of interest of items on
the agenda
nope uh questions on notice from
councilors there are no questions so we
move on to item six to matters referred
from
from other committees and there was a
report from the overview on scrutiny
committee relating to the litter
strategy
2022-2025 councilor Stuart Wilson
chairman of the overview and scrutiny
committee will introduce the report
we're on up we'll see item number six so
I think at that point if I hand over to
councilor Wilson thank you chairman
members the um
the report of um of the committee was
actually very positively received sorry
the report for Mr holton's very
positively received by members of the
overview and scrutiny committee
I think
Mr hot will agree that this is work in
progress It's actually the strategy is
evolving so this isn't the finished
product at the moment and you'll see
when you look at the appendix there are
a number of placeholders there but
that's because there is is still work in
progress
um
the three key themes that are in the
strategy the first is education and
awareness and what we're trying to do
here is change people's behavior so
we're trying to stop people from
literally rather than coming in
afterwards and necessarily finding them
looking at better
cleansing and literary infrastructure
and there are upgrades to some of the
facilities already on order
also we're looking at improving
enforcement and that was one of the key
issues that members of the overview and
scrutiny committee were particularly
interested in and if you look at the
report paragraph 4.1 the last bullet
point on page 6.3
one of the
main concerns of members of my committee
was the scale of fines and the scale of
fines are actually very low and they
don't really seem to act as a deterrent
one of the examples was the fine is less
than the cost of hiring a skip
so people will flight it so that that
was an area of concern and we were
looking for that to be reviewed
um if I move on to the before we go to
the recommendations I'll hand over to Mr
hotten really if anyone's got any
questions on the strategy itself
any questions from members
no I would just say that well we'll let
Mr hotman speak and then um
we'll make further comments
a bit
because I'm working on yes there we go
I'm pretty pretty spoken out enough
really
um and thank you I mean I think um you
you've covered the main points of it
there's three three themes uh it
reflects the um uh the national knitted
strategy uh that was originally set out
in 2017
um and the code of practice Solitaire
which has been revised in 2019 and so
really it just sort of I think a lot of
the work was already ongoing but I think
it just gives it a more of a coordinated
approach to to how we approach litter
across across the districts so it so I
wouldn't say this is entirely um a new
Venture I think at least two of those
aspects are something we've already been
um and taking but I think it just gives
it a more coordinated approach across
Services uh I think I think with the
matter of enforcement a further pay for
will be coming back into overview and
scrutiny and then on to the executive
consideration I think that's something
that needs to be looked at a bit more
detailed I think I acknowledge that
other time oh they're just like thinking
of you and scrutiny first isn't in the
matter
thank you Mr Totten uh Council sparing
did you wish to add anything uh oh I beg
your pardon it might be Council Wilson
wants to come back
uh no I don't think so chairman I think
uh Mr Hart myself have had an ongoing
conversation about this we know
um that this is his work in progress
as it says in the report some of the
items that need to be addressed are
already uh being put in situ locating
mapping waste areas dog areas dog bin
areas all this sort of stuff new Bins
being ordered it's all in in process and
they will be coming in as soon as they
arrive within our Realms
um I think the other area that Mr
hotness touched on is the actual
Enforcement issue and there are plans
for both he and I uh to discuss this in
Greater detail in the very near future
with third parties thank you Jim
thank you for that Council FD
question
um he says in there you're doing I.E
been looking at where all the bins are
going to go
um I found it quite difficult in the
past to actually get new Bins cited
because there are a couple votes
especially in great white cream which
are about
half a mile long and as bus stops along
and we've actually no litter bins so
people stand there and drop litter
um how would they will we have any more
resources to be able to empty those bins
I don't think it's the cost of the bins
I think it's the empty end which
sometimes is the problem
um I think I mean so the um the bin
infrastructure is to be reviewed uh I
mean I think there are uh in places bins
where there doesn't need to be bins if
that makes sense and there are others I
think we need additional bins but that I
think needs to be um looked at in a sort
of methodological way and so that set
out within um the code of practice for
litter so that's what we follow the
national code of practice on how to
assess that sort of matter so the answer
is yes and we were considering um the
installation of new Bins but also
perhaps removal of
um bins where they're inappropriate
located as well
thank you
thank you very much any more questions
okay
um certainly another good example of
pre-scrutiny uh you know I think it's
really helpful uh really valuable to
have that contribution of pre-scrutiny I
certainly wrote at the bottom of my page
against the bullet point but you covered
it about the scales of fines and
enforcement
it's no good having a policy and us
talking about zero tolerance and all of
that if we're not actually enforcing it
um you know
certainly one or two authorities have
come in for criticism because they have
been extremely
um
microscopic in terms of the way they
have been dealing with enforcement but
you know it's just not acceptable to
literary District people quite rightly
talk about air quality and you know
other forms of pollution but litter
pollution is disgraceful we're fortunate
in the communities you have a number of
voluntary bodies that care about their
community and actually go out and take
that much pride but
that on one side of the equation that's
brilliant on the other side of the
equation we want to stop those
Scoundrels that do pollute with litter
so a good report certainly I will look
forward to hearing how we plan to
enforce looking at our scale of fees I
thought the draft policy is
excellent
um
and unless there's any other questions I
think we moved straight to the
recommendations as set out on page 6.5
and members I'll read them out and it is
proposed that the council recommends to
the executive that the draft letter
strategy be approved as set out in the
appendix the delegated authority be
given to the assistant director of place
and environment in consultation with the
portfolio holder for environment to
oversee the design and layout of the
document and make minor changes to the
litter strategy in advance of
publication just to be concerned about
the title of the job title there
foreign
of just checking but it is the
director of the environment and there
was over that modification in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for environment to overseeing the design
and layout of the document and make
minor changes to the list of strategy in
advance of publication uh that's uh
number three the sponsorship from local
businesses be investigated and for that
detailed proposals regarding enforcement
and costs of implementation be brought
back to the overview and scrutiny
committee for scrutiny members are you
happy for us to take those on block
can I ask for uh
recommendations agreed agreed
that is unanimous
thank you
right we move on to the next item
I can sort my papers out
which is item seven uh report to the uh
executive from uh
on our financial management report
quarter one 22 23 and I'm past Passover
initially to the deputy leader councilor
Cheryl Rowe to report
good thank you
okay
members executive is asked to note the
quarter one 2023 Revenue budget and
capital positions set out in sections
three and four of the report and
detailed in appendices one and sorry one
to four
the purpose of the report is to set out
a forecast revenue and capital budget
positions for the
2022-2023 financial year as of the end
of the first quarter
the latest Revenue budget of 12.1
million
changes to the original budget are due
to drawdowns from Reserve which are
detailed in appendix one
the forecast outturn at quarter one is
12.5 million which gives a projected
overspend of 0.4 million
the forecasts within the reports include
an estimate an estimate of increased pay
inflation of 2022 2023 which is yet to
be confirmed and includes other known
cost pushes
where this information is available
however it should be noted that there
are Financial risks arising from the
current economic Outlook which cannot be
Quantified with accuracy at this present
stage
are likely to impact further on the
council's costs of services over the
course of 2022-2023 and Beyond
it should also be noted that the
financial position does not yet fully
reflect the cost impact of changes
agreed under the one team strategic
partnership program
which is still subject to change and an
agreement of final arrangements and
recruitment to vacant posts
the variances across the individual
portfolio budgets are set out in more
detail in the body of the report and
appendix too
whilst the council is not currently
anticipating the need to reduce services
this year the financial position will
have to be closely monitored over 22 23
in light of a significant inflationary
pressures it is facing
this is likely to make budget set in for
2023-24 and Beyond even more challenging
than normal
the latest Capital program budget for 22
23 6.3 million the forecast outturn on
the council's capital program at quarter
one is 4.2 million
the major atom with slippage against the
revised 23 22-23 budget as the asset
development program pinned an agreement
of the stop-go decision point
the table at appendix 3 summarizes the
project Capital position by service area
appendix 4 sets out some key financial
indicators for the council in more
detail
thank you chairman if there's any
questions I'm sure Naomi you'll be happy
to answer
thank you very much indeed for that
councilor FD
thank you chairman I think these
questions are more for
uh
Tracy Lily
yes
um thank you very much for the appendix
on the end of the report about the cost
of living crisis
perhaps I should make it a bit clearer
I'd like to take that as a separate part
of okay so I should have been a bit
clearer
um Tracy Lily was looking extremely
concerned that she might have to give
full details of the financial statement
but it is two two in one so if we can
deal with the first bit and I should
have made it really clear apologies for
that uh are there any questions
um Naomi I should have asked you did you
wish to add to any anything that
councilor Rose has said
okay
um are there any questions on the
financial statement
right for good order I'm not going to go
to the recommendation on that yet until
we finished talking about the rest of
the reports
um there is a addendum
I have to say a little disappointed it's
an addendum because I would have liked
to have seen it given
um
its level of importance as its own
separate item
um because it was back in May or June
that I spoke to the chief exec we
obviously have regular one-to-ones and
we both acknowledge that the cost of
living issues
was coming down the tracks soon after we
became aware of the conflict in Ukraine
and the impact that I was happening but
my focus as leader here was to really
consider how we can address and support
our residents through a most difficult
time obviously it's attracted a lot of
media attention and
[Music]
since this report was written which is
about two weeks ago you couldn't believe
the number of changes so it now looks
two weeks later like a out of date
report because the number of facts have
changed
um indeed if we come back to the first
part of the report we are starting to
see signs of how the cost of living
issues as it's being
badged are impacting on us as an
authority because impact on wages impact
on heating all affect us as a business
so not only does it affect people
domestically in their domestic lives but
it also affects businesses
it's down to a number of factors
um I don't think I'm going to turn this
all into economists tonight but the
simple fact is you know there are fuel
issues there's cost of petrol
interestingly enough and I've lived long
enough to see these things go through
waves and from time to time there is
changes in in fuel prices I paid last
week uh one pound 49 per liter whereas a
few months ago I was paying over two
pounds a liter so already we're seeing
some of those
that volatility change we've seen
government announcements over the last
few few weeks that have put in new caps
on energy so some of the concerns that
were existing are being addressed and so
if we go through the reports
I'm afraid to absolutely no one's fault
it's not an accurate report now because
some of the predictions about what it
was going to do to domestic household
bills in terms of heating have been
changed by the
2500 energy cap which has been put on on
fuel
huge volatility wages growth is an
impact and all these things tend to be
out of our control
as an authority but the impact of what
happens does fall within our control you
look at 3.8 so as recently as last
Thursday the bank of England base rate
is now 2.25 percent so you know there's
a another example
um
3.7 cost of diesel is
significantly when it is coming back
down again
um rent across the UK at a record high
three percent increase
uh
3.10 we now know from the budget last
Friday the National Insurance isn't now
going to affect us see all the all the
volunteer volunteered agility uh in this
uh 3.11 is accurate and this is
government centrally announcing how
people will be supported uh for a
hundred pound Energy discount
and
council tax rebate for for people in
property bands a to d
300 pounds one-off payment to pensioners
those of us are a pensionable age May
well appreciate that
um and uh 150 pounds so to to people
with disability
and 200 pound cost living payment by the
household support so there's a range of
measures and there's that there's other
measures here
um
so
what can we do as an authority
um what we have done is an authority and
perhaps I should pass over to Tracy
Lilly otherwise I'll steal all your
thunder but you have been working
extremely hard behind the scenes and
creating a number of tools because what
we said as an authority we could only
really be a sign poster at the end of
the day we haven't got money we're not
authorized to give Financial advice to
people but we can support our partners
in the cab
um we which we do I believe quite
generously already we can sign posts to
the various services and we can make
sure that we are understanding and
supportive to people that actually need
to pay Council bills particularly
council tax bills so I hope I haven't
stolen all your thunder but Tracy Lily
can I pass over to you as director of
communities in health and talk through
from your perspective Where We Are
is a new environment for me
yeah I mean there's no Thunder stealing
here it's it's a real critical issue for
all of us across the country and what
we've been trying to do is stay focused
on the support that we can provide to
the residents and that's not about us
providing it as a council it's making
sure that they are at that point of
contact at the first point because we
haven't got time to waste so I'm really
pleased to announce that we've got a
fantastic website a web page up and
running I can give the link to that that
it's very comprehensive the problem we
have it's a bit like I say herding cats
it changes every day I mean it it
doesn't last no longer than three days
but we're really on top of making sure
that that is up to date at every
conceivable turn we've developed an
action plan I have brought copies of it
because I do like to show people how
hard the team work but I just will add a
caveat that it is still draft and we're
still working through it because what
we're trying to do is work together on
it across both councils so there's that
collaboration and that support for the
residents we're setting up a working
group which is fantastic the support
we're getting from external Partners the
fire service the police you know all our
community groups and volunteers it's
it's a real team effort it's on the
health and well-being board agenda so
you'll just have to bear with us it's a
living document reaction plan and the
idea is as it says in the recommendation
that we'll bring it back to exec
regularly so that members can have a
view of it they can comment on it and
what we would like to know is if there's
the ideas that we bring the action plan
back to you but if there's any data or
metrics that you want us to bring to you
from that so it might be that you want
to know how many people access the food
banks or you know the support services
that are out there we can do that as
well so that you've got an idea of
what's going on but the the focus of the
the team at the moment is to make sure
that we're getting the support out there
we're looking at all sorts of things
including there's the warm spaces warm
hubs which we don't really like the
terminology of
because it's there's a stigma attached
to it I think it's not about poverty or
anything like that you know it's the
likes of me as a working person that
needs to access these areas so there's a
whole mapping exercise going on across
Essex we're also doing local mapping so
that we know where all of the venues and
the facilities and the organization
organizations are that people can access
because it's not about creating
necessarily these hubs or these spaces
it's about what's out there already and
what people can access in their local
community so yeah it's it's a changing
beast and I thought I'd earned my spurs
when I was made it coveredly and then I
jump direct to it so now I'm constantly
living I can't escape it but we're
really on top of it and we will continue
to be on top of it and we're happy to
answer any questions that members might
have the website is the real key for us
so we're going to make sure that that's
up to date and we'll bring the action
plan back to members and I'm happy to
give a copy of the action plan now so
that you can have a look at some of the
stuff that's being done but there are
some adjustments that need to be made
for both
councils if that makes sense
all right have you got copies you can
post I have got copies with me yeah
actually I'm just so I was ably
supported to be able to bring these to
you and while those are being passed out
are there any particular questions
councilor ft
thank you chairman right just a couple
of things
one is I'm you might be in this plan
which I haven't seen so please don't get
too annoyed if asking
silly questions but
I'm looking at
3.12 where it's giving support to
people and it seems to be
I sort of classify myself as working
class but working class seems to be
missing from there because especially
two parents two kids come Christmas they
don't want to say no to the kids they're
going to spend money on presents and
stuff like that
spend money on heating where they've
never had a problem before this is such
a big
difference in the cost of everything
there doesn't seem to be anything for
them I know it's not for us to do it but
maybe this maybe we could ask about
Senpai sign posting from them from
central government
because I think that's going to be
that's going to be a lot of people are
going to be having a problem there and
also on
3.13 where we've had officers go to
few profit fuel poverty workshops
again if it's in here to
pardon me but
that information
needs to trickle down a bit quicker
because especially where you're talking
about the warm places it's I think today
was been the first real cold day I've
been out working it was it was chilly so
this is going to be something that needs
to be done pretty quickly
so don't
I know we do things quickly RDC and I'm
sure Brentwood does as well but Essex we
need to nag Essex
because a lot of these places will be
theirs
um
so just updating on that the mapping you
talked about so great great job so far
thank you yeah just to reassure you it's
like I mentioned in my previous comment
it is for you know people that are out
there working and the support and the
guidance and the um kind of signposting
on the website is for everybody we've
kind of broken it down into five themes
so it's support with bills and um what
is it about trying to remember what it
was now
bills and money and support with food
support and well-being support at work
and the go green so we've tried to
literally cover every conceivable and
it's what I was kind of referring to
around the warm hubs it's not just for
those that are on a low income or are on
benefits it's for everybody and so
that's why we're trying to remove the
stigma in a sense and that one of the
things that we're looking at doing and
you're very right about Essex they're
doing their mapping exercise but we're
doing our own local mapping exercise
because we need to move quite quickly
and these
facilities and everything are up and
running already it's just around making
sure people know where they are so
they're accessible
thank you thank you Council award thank
you very much chairman
um no it's it's it's very good to hear
that you've updated because obviously
this particular addendum was probably
out of date
before it was even printed you know just
moving along is going so quickly there
was a very good point though that
councilor FD made about Working Families
who've who've never actually
contemplated being in the position that
they're actually going to be finding
themselves in and it's just looking for
help for budgetary means how do you
budget better because they probably had
a period where it's been free spending
the money comes in everything has been
low inflation there's been no problem
and all of a sudden it's a big
turnaround and they've never had that
before I know I've had it
ages ago and and understood about the
various ups and downs as as the leader
has actually said you know I've
witnessed the various ups and downs that
you can go through and how you have to
sort of work it out and accept that
we're living in a difficult period we
will get out of it and I'm very
convinced of this I'm very positive
about the means that are actually going
about
actually relieving the situation where
we're looking to be more self-sufficient
in energy and food I think that's very
important but for the moment we need to
actually concentrate on helping those
without any stigma
can you budget how have you budget
you're probably got enough money coming
in but are you using it properly and I
think that is that's a very important
question that we need to help with yeah
I totally agree with you and I am one of
those people I'm already having those
conversations with the kids we can rock
the tumble dryer until the end of the
month and then that tumble dryer has
been switched off it's a really serious
issue and that's why I think we need to
be agile because some of the you know
the push was coming through about around
warm spaces but actually it's the
financial issues for people that need
addressing and cab are doing some
training for Frontline staff but also
for us as a council it's not just our
problem it's everybody's problem and it
that affects our staff so we need to
make sure they're supported but also
there's that Common Thread and
commonality of language that's used so
that everybody that works for us knows
where to go where to sign post people to
and the support they can get from
themselves because we're going to
potentially say and you'll you'll
realize I talk too much you could
potentially see staff leaving for better
paid jobs because they need that income
to come in so we're on top of it that's
all I can say but yeah if anybody's got
any good suggestions I'm always my doors
are always open thanks thanks very much
Council Belton
and first off well done well done I'm
getting on the front foot of this
um hopefully what these actions will do
is prevent some of these people that are
being spoken about finding themselves in
that situation so hopefully we can flip
someone to the positive side of it
um just one question because it always
gets asked those of our residents that
don't have access to the website or
aren't comfortable using websites how do
we signposts then because there's
certainly going to be a small minority
of people that need a different sort of
assistance yeah we've discussed this
actually as a team and what we've said
is we can put all this information out
in leaflets and pamphlets and everything
else but it changes so quickly so what
we're going to do is put some
information out there as where they can
go and get this information but also use
our community groups and particularly
like the Hub at the mega Center and
other Outreach places where people can
go and access that information and we're
looking to do some Outreach work as well
and then do that in some of these places
where people go so whether there be warm
space or whatever they might be we'll
take that information to the people
because it's a real it's a real
challenge for us and we need to make
sure that everybody knows about it so
that you can just have that conversation
with your neighbor even but yeah if it
we did think about a leaflet but it's as
only good as the day it's printed at the
moment and it changes so quickly but we
will get that information out I'll just
come back very quickly
um just just one thing to consider and
you probably already have by the sounds
of it but maybe posters in doctor
surgery is just letting people know that
they can look at a website or they can
make a phone call to get the advice and
because some of our vulnerable will end
up in the doctors inevitably yeah no
you're absolutely right that's why we've
raised a health well-being building it's
now on the health and wellbeing Board of
gender it's really key so you've got all
over 50 Partners around that table so
it's using all of those available
sources that you've got because like I
said it's all about problems yeah thank
you
a range of agencies at councilor Webb
yeah thank you yes I welcome this report
um I guess from my point of view this is
a real problem
um obviously we know that
um you know from personal experience I'm
linking with fair share and last Friday
night I went to waitrose and I collected
about seven crates of food and then
distributed them Saturday morning to
five families in our districts so it is
a real issue I guess my question and the
reason I mention that is just looking
through the work stream too where you've
mentioned in terms of looking to work
with
those that need particularly food
there's funding mentioned but there's no
actual budgets attached to that there's
no actual numbers there so it's lovely
to read that there's discretionary
funding available Government funding
allocated I feel much happier if there
was some funding numbers there and we
could actually know that we're going to
make a difference in our district
yeah I mean like I said it's it's a
living document so we're continually
working on it what we're doing at the
moment is we're actually
Consulting with all of our partners and
food bank particularly they come back
very quickly actually and said they've
seen an increase in in people accessing
their services so we can identify where
that support is needed first and we've
already spoken to Essex around that sort
of funding but that will like I said
that will evolve and we'll look at what
funding we can offer as we move along
because we need to make sure that I'm
not a knee-jerk reaction kind of person
I want it to get to where it needs to be
as quickly as I can get it there and I
want it to go to the right place so once
we've got that in order then we'll we'll
get out there and do whatever we can to
support the residents and the rest of
the community
thank you councilor Williams
thank you Tracy it's a great report
thank you
um one of my concerns is is that people
are frightened now to switch the heating
on there are going to be lots of people
now that it's not going to be as bad as
they think it might be because of all
the help they're getting and we need to
get the message out there that whatever
happens you must keep warm
another thing is a recent health and
well-being meeting I went to
um the fire brigade were there and we
were discussing the fact that they are
very concerned now about the use of
paraffin eaters gas heaters camping
gasps stoves and things as they are
expecting to have more house fires
they're going to need to attend so we
need to get some information out there
that people have to use extra care yeah
well I've already engaged with the fire
service they're on the front foot as
well they've been brilliant and they've
said they're also concerned about people
buying the and I never thought this
would ever happen disposable barbecues
that use outside using them indoors so
they're part of our working group moving
forward so yeah we're working with them
already they've been fantastic and
another big issue that they're having
with these is that club and Oxford
carbon monoxide poisoning is going is
increasing yeah yeah
Council of water
let me come back
um just a suggestion you might have
probably thought about it but obviously
as things get colder the residents are
going to be finding it's easier to go
out and be in places that are actually
warm and identifying there may be cafes
they may be pubs they could be anything
where it's easy just to go in and keep
warm
are you going to put it out into those
type of places so that again you know
we're covering a wide
gamma of our population yeah I may not
have explained myself properly that's
what the kind of warm hubs warm spaces
we just don't like the terminology so
we're looking at cozy hubs you know all
kinds of different things and one of the
things that we talked about even today
was once we've got that information of
where all of these facilities are and
there'll be running activities anyway
but it might be that we look at doing
some kind of mini accreditation scheme
so rather than saying you know if you
can't afford to put your heating on you
can go there we just give them a little
logo and the list there'll be list of
you know
Leisure centers all sorts of stuff and
then against if they make a set of
criteria against their name will be just
a little logo saying cozy Hub so people
can just look at that and go oh I know
that's where I can go to get warm so
yeah that that will happen okay thank
you okay members look
um you can see by the discussion
um around the table
the care and concern amongst everyone
about you know recognizing the
importance
um but we've also got to remember we are
just one agency
it's about a multi-agency approach and
we always have limited resource on
anything that we apply our hand to and
it's actually how we maximize that
resource or maximize the resource to get
maximum effect within the community and
you know the report demonstrates how
fast moving this all is uh I think
you're planning to bring back a report
each month to Executive I think it's
going to get worse before it gets better
because the winter months come on us
we have a part to play but we've got to
recognize we cannot be all things to all
people however much our social
conscience might wish us to be we do
have to temper and we have some
responsibility you know there are it was
all very nice when rates were going down
but people get used to low rates but
there will be people around this table
that can remember base rate at 16
percent
um they can remember mortgage rates not
unusually at eight or nine ten percent
we can remember cost of living running
you know inflation rates running at six
seven percent
um so this is not new to us what is new
is the fact that it's the perfect storm
of so many issues and the fact that
we're coming from low inflation low
interest rates
um and a reasonably
buoyant economy
um you know it's still buoyant in the
sense of employment rates but there are
pressures we cannot set ourselves up as
money advisors we may all have our views
about how people should prioritize their
spending and we live in a country where
we allow people to make choices
so so there we are but there will be
some real difficult cases within our
community
there will sadly be some people that
exploit it within our community
um and we have to somehow differentiate
and make sure that our resource goes to
those people that are in very genuine
need not being judgmental at all so I
welcome the reports
um it is a shame that this isn't being
recorded tonight because I think a
recording would have got out into the
community our real passion our real
commitment and the early warning that we
put into this both across Brentwood
Borough Council of Oxford District
Council as our partner the seriousness
with which we're approaching this and
our genuine desire so thank you very
much indeed for all your hard work and
unless there's any further points I'm
going to go back to the original
recommendation of the first part of the
report but could I ask that in future it
is given the significance of being a
report in its own right because I would
like to raise the profile rather than
bury it as an addendum
um but uh
if we can go to the decision being
recommended
on page 7.1 at 1.1 to note the quarter 1
20 22 23 Revenue budget and capital
positions set out in sections three and
four below and detailed in appendices
one to four is that noted members
thank you and then if we can turn to
page 7.25
and specifically the recommendations
relating to the cost of living a crisis
at
1.1 and 1.2 that an action plan will be
produced by officers which will be
presented to a future executive when we
say future executive we can leave that
as it is but I would like to see next
executive please we'll leave that as it
is but
I'd like to see monthly you and I
discusses a bit earlier but it is so
volatile as a subject I think we need to
really be on top of it and every
executive and give it the profile that
it deserves so at a future executive and
that the action plan is regularly
reviewed updated and reported back to
the executive is that agreed members
thank you
we then turn to item eight
which is a report from the portfolio
holder climate and economy on the
sustained sustainability strategy update
councilor Belton
um okay so I'm I'm trusting that
everyone's had a chance to glance over
the report
um given that the ambitious deadline of
2030 and the council being carbon
neutral is fast approaching we thought
it would be a good idea to update on
what's been going on in regards to that
area
and there's a very simple table set out
on pages 8.2 and 8.3
um which essentially highlights some of
the main actions that are ongoing
um
with anything carbon neutral related and
changes they take time there's a lot of
research to be done and markers will be
attending a lot of meetings having a lot
of discussions about the right strategy
to take forward
um you'll see that within there things
like the electric vehicles it seems like
a simple decision to make but it is not
at all and there's a lot of implications
to consider and it's important to get
things right the first time so time
needs to be taken
the sustainable sustainability strategy
survey has now closed there was a very
good response from that and the hope
will be that either in October or
November for Council we will be able to
bring forward a draft sustainability
strategy for consideration
um but ultimately I think we just wanted
to let members know that a lot of work
is going on where the carbon neutral
Target is um is concerned and in
addition we've gone that step further
we've had the launch of Reba which is
still very much in its infancy
um but it's there now and it exists so
that we could help businesses also start
their journey to carbon neutrality and
arguably the most important is setting
things up so that residents can also
take those steps forward which will help
with the cost of living crisis if they
can afford their bills in a more
sustainable Manner and so I think that's
it from me Marcus may want to add some
detail
foreign
thank you just uh I think just to add
later
um as a strategy it is a district-wide
strategy
and therefore it's not something that
can be achieved uh solely by the council
I mean in a sense the the council
footpreneur I mean zone is actually
quite uh small but it's how we can
influence others within the district to
take action and therefore it's the
consultation stage is actually quite
critical which is why we have taken some
time over this so so in many ways the
draft strategy has set out
um an opportunity to discuss with other
partners um how we can how we can
achieve those aims but also that it's
about establishing a a
um
firm network from which we can actually
work upon to actually deliver this
strategy I think that's an absolutely
key stage of consultation stage and
that's that's being undertaken through
the um
questionnaires and surveys but also
workshops and individual meetings with
key stakeholders and we have some as
councilor has already mentioned we have
to bring their signs back in October
November to fall Council
um sort of a finalized version of the
thrust strategy happy to take any
questions thank you thank you any
questions members
Council board yeah it's it's actually an
observation uh just going back to the
previous
item
it it does prove at this moment just how
Reliant we are on carbon with gas
with petrol diesel we are highly reliant
on those items and I am concerned I want
to see us to go in a Direction
of Net Zero but it's that intervening
period where we're suddenly ditching one
thing all of a sudden and we don't have
anything in between this is a real
concern to me that we could end up in a
very poor place if we don't acknowledge
that we're going to have to have some
form of energy sustainability
for quite a time and personally you know
if the sun doesn't shine and the wind
doesn't blow we've got problems if we
are going in the route of of that in
that direction so I think it's got to be
looking fairly and radically I suppose
at a mixed economy and you know we can
dash for carbon
and I can understand going to Net Zero
and there are things out there that will
help us but you know we do need to
consider that if we throw everything out
with the bath water so to speak we could
be in real trouble as is being shown by
Russia cutting off its gas and the Havoc
it's causing in Europe and you know how
economies are literally tumbling into
disarray so we have to be very very
careful in how we observe things
it's a quick question Marcus is one of
our partners I'll take his Essex County
Council it is indeed yes and are you
talking to the Essex County Council
transport strategy
is that part of this correct yes okay
all right and I have a chat with you
after about some concerns I've got done
on board your videos with them
thank you any more questions
no um look
two or three years ago this Council was
forward-thinking enough to set itself an
ambitious Target of being carbon neutral
by 2030.
um
and uh
and we set up a carbon neutral working
group
um
along the way there were those that were
dying for us to declare a climate change
emergency
um
and for me I know supported by members
there was a feeling that that was just
ticking boxes and I'm very anti just
ticking boxes and saying job done what
we are demonstrating and we created the
portfolio in May climate and economy and
I think those two are quite rightly
linked but planning has a big part to
play in it and indeed right throughout
the um throughout the portfolios this
needs to be in our culture in terms of
the way we do our day-to-day business
I'm delighted
um that the portfolio holder for climate
and economy
is doing an absolutely Splendid job in
terms of raising the profile and us
taking the whole subject of climate
change extremely seriously but backing
it with a range of actions so I'd
certainly like to thank the director of
policy and Delivery for his work that
he's doing so far and others in the team
because it is a teamwork actually albeit
that tends to be led by an individual so
I'm very very pleased with what we are
doing because we're doing things rather
than just making statements and Ticking
boxes
certainly uh portfolio holder
councilor Belton along with me attended
the climate
carbon literacy
group a week or two ago
and it was one of those sort of
Education forums but you know it feeds
into our knowledge on the subject and
highlights the importance of us doing
our part and it is dare I say within the
context of the world issue it's a very
small part very very small part but at
least we're taking our role extremely
seriously so thank you very much indeed
no further questions on that
in which case would move to the decision
being recommended at 1.1 to note the
progress being made to deliver and
finalize the draft sustainability
strategy is that noted
thank you very much indeed
um at um
756 that concludes the meeting and I'd
certainly like to thank all officers for
their attendance thank you for your hard
work thank you members thank you for
your hard work thank you for members of
the public for uh sitting there and
listening to us thank you to everyone
and some of us will be back here for a
meeting at 9 30 and we've got a uh just
a
between so there we are thank you very
much and good night to those who are
leaving us